Gerard PK goes Instagram official with
his girlfriend Clara Chia Marty
following his split from Shakira it's
been quite a journey the retired Soccer
Star shared this sweet snap of him
cuddling up to his lady love who he's
been seeing since last summer and while
Gerard didn't caption the pick the photo
seems to say it all as it comes just
weeks after his ex Shakira dropped her
breakup Anthem bizarre rap music
sessions volume 53 where the singer
seemingly shaves Gerard and his
girlfriend
[Music]
yeah and that translates to I wish you
the best with my supposed replacement I
don't even know what happened to you
you're so weird that I can't even tell
you apart I'm worth two 22s Lara is now
23 years old and it seems one of
Shakira's lyrics has caught Gerard's
attention
those tracks translate to you traded a
Ferrari for a twingo you traded a Rolex
for Ocasio and Gerard well he fired back
with get this partnering with
cassiah
yep the soccer pro announced that Cassio
sent the Spanish Kings League wrist
watches and that he got the brand to
sponsor it and while Gerard didn't say
when the deal occurred or if it had
anything to do with Shakira's new song a
commentator offered his guess telling
the group it was because of Shakira song
foreign
announced last June in a joint statement
that they were separating after 12 years
together that relationship with oneself
in which so many so many things come to
play you know especially uh being
committed to your own goals in life and
not giving up and not abandoning or
throwing in the towel too soon just
because the environment tries to bring
you down the Grammy winner opened up
about the split in October telling L
magazine it was incredibly difficult
Shakira said the relationship she had
with Gerard once felt sacred but it's
been turned into something vulgarized
and cheapened by the scandalous
headlines surrounding their breakup
calling it quote probably The Darkest
Hour of my life
foreign